well I mean I don't like guys in general
so I think he should go to hell right
and jail here by the way he's
competition dude maybe this chick will
fight me if I agree with exactly her
yeah she's probably hottest she's dating
him bro like she's probably smoking hot
right
[Music]
so you guys know what about the new
Marvel villain
his name is Jonathan Majors Jonathan
majors
yes okay so he was just an Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumanias he was also just
in the new Creed movie do you guys watch
any of those by the way I did Hans Mania
what'd you think I thought it was whack
everyone said that is it what was whack
about it it just wasn't that great I
think also I think it was necessary for
the the franchise it's necessary for the
overarching like
um phase in the story building and stuff
like that but just as a movie and as it
honestly felt like I was watching Avatar
meets strange world that I think it was
by Disney or whatever me it's like it
just didn't feel like Super Fresh
original epic also Ant-Man is like oh
that's kind of okay you know what I mean
superheroes so I think from like just
like a Fan's point of view you're not
necessarily like super invested their
entire like family Arc and again this is
just opinion I don't know what other
people think but like from Ant-Man the
WASP his parents and all the whole whack
I just think it's whack yeah it's not
that tight you know what I mean the
story the backstory the purpose their
intention what about the George read the
new one because I haven't yet but I do
want to watch that I do want to watch
did you get invested in Creed no I
didn't I liked it which one I didn't I
didn't dislike it compared to some
people okay I liked it that's cool
and uh that's awesome
okay I guess that's the end of that no
that's [__] sick I'm feeling some
passive aggressive energy no no no I
think that's so I think that's so sick
and I think it's epic
you just doubled down on the passive
aggressive energy you're hiding it with
this like fake [__]
that you're making it worse look I think
the Creed
is a movie franchise
Jonathan
means one of the movies of all time he's
he plays Kang the Conqueror from Ant-Man
and he's also set up to be like the new
Thanos yeah and Marvel because they have
stronger than Thanos technically do you
think he was cool do you think he was
cool in the movie I think he's capable
of being cool
man yeah he was also in like Army
commercials and [__] too right yeah yeah
he was just in in a bunch of army
commercials he's killing him right now
he was but well at least he didn't kill
anybody thank God but he was arrested
for assault oh strangulation oh
harassment oh my God New York City oh
that's that's MMA yeah assault
strangulation that's two that's that's
striking striking Yep this guy's
well-rounded yeah this is all legendary
he denied it though right Yep this is
all ledge we don't know that this
happened where did it New York City I
mean like was it at a bar or something
um so or a bedroom the victim
so this is a dependental clip domestic
dispute with a 30 year old woman please
oh it had to be a woman 11 am what she
was was 30. there was a 911 call inside
an apartment in the Manhattan
neighborhood of Chelsea which is a fan
everyone knows Chelsea
um in New York
um they put him into custody without
incident the victim had minor injuries
to her head and neck and was removed to
a hospital in stable condition damn he's
no longer in police custody as of
Saturday night after this incident damn
he has denied wrongdoing completely he
says he'll be cleared he says this is
all [__] so it's all up in the air
right now but the lady just fell down
the stairs herself our early predictions
what do we think well we don't know
because rough sex
maybe because we don't we don't know if
he actually did it right that's yeah
because they don't there's no charges
his management has denied it his PR I
thought you guys were believe all women
what's wrong with you no we're just
asking what do you guys think that's all
early prediction why do but not when
they're 30. okay yeah that's different
I'm always inclined to just think like I
don't know so why judge because I don't
know yet yeah I don't know I have the
best time to judge when you don't know
no no no no no the best is when you only
have a little bit of information and
then you want to burn them at the stake
I think that's the American way well I
mean I don't like guys in general so I
think he should go to hell right and
jail guys here by the way he's
competition dude maybe this chick will
[__] me if I agree with exactly yeah
she's probably hot as hell if she's
dating him bro like she's probably
smoking hot right so that's so smart I
think for sure and if we take them out
of the equation that means they're not
he's not [__] dead weight no he's out
of the way he's out of the way and it
gives me a chance a guy like me right
between the legs because she just
doesn't know it yet straight shot yeah
she's out here with these [__] guys
these [__] who are not like they
don't treat her like right not me you
would treat her so much better dude a
thousand percent she does need to be
safe exactly a thousand percent and she
doesn't know it but she doesn't notice
me yet because I'm not a famous actor
yeah I bet she would love Hawaii too oh
my God I think she would just fall for
you immediately you think she like June
beaters I think she likes Boba everybody
likes bubbles in this scenario we can
get her on the show in a scenario I
don't have a job I don't have a job I
stay home a lot I uh comment in this
scenario scenario you don't get a lot of
daylight but you're looking forward to
it nope
in this case too I just think that you
know what was he doing in the room in
the first place alone beating up a girl
yeah how innocent is he saying yes is he
like I don't know who this is like go
this way to herself I believe in dude
I'm a I'm a team jail right now in most
cases when girls get beat the [__] up
right Jonathan major side and then the
girl's like yo he [__] me up right
like how like statistically like how
much of that is like I'm just lying or
how much is that she got [__] up my
thing is like that's true what how could
it benefit my sex life so like you know
if I'm gay then I probably start with
him and I'm like hey dude like maybe you
like what could [__] down the road I'm
for sure
we was just low-key talking about this
with the Gwyneth Paltrow story right
dude [__] uh optometrist lower than
chiropractor doctor or whatever the [__]
crashes into her skin and then is like
let me Sue your ass for 3.1 million
dollars even though you didn't get
injured yeah and it's kind of like
suggestion to you yeah you sue somebody
because you think you can take something
from them if there was just an economy
class bloke like myself he's probably
not gonna sue me right same thing we
don't know who this chick is but
Jonathan Majors was recently in two
number one movies in the box office hits
like back to back that hadn't been done
in a long time you know what I'm saying
that hadn't been done a long time for
Ant-Man Quantum and Creed Three and it's
like he's got something to lose so all
I'm saying is the math and the
ingredients you're leaning towards
believing him well hey we got to say
something about it like I believe most
women that's my mom and look at this guy
he's the leaf most women Vietnam now
he's coming back here saying bloke and
[__] yeah yeah come on dude
we get it bro this guy's so worldly
argument
it's got European now pick that [__] up
over there I guess Vietnam's in Europe
exactly hello
I want to see how [__] up her face
looked
cheese before or after well I kind of
that was a mixer I would love I want to
see if there's anything yeah no the
question is more like what high heels
Where She Went
is this what the movies has she seen
recently is this an Amber Heard moment
or does she need help Nick's like are we
sure she lived in Chelsea a lot of
people say they live in Chelsea
I feel like whenever you hear a story
just an inkling of like someone hurt one
of your female friends I think there's
this weird Primal feeling of I gotta
murder this guy now like a protective
nature yeah like just in in just real
talk with people that I know yeah I'm
like
oh I gotta kill this fool like and she's
like oh no no no he just he didn't he
didn't like the way I made udon and I'm
all like no he's gotta [__] die you
know like you gotta save her I gotta no
I'm not saving my aunt you know what I
mean I'm not trying to [__] my aunt
that's crazy thanks for clearing that up
that's good but there is I think there
is a weird like male primal thing that
goes on where it's like oh she's in
danger I have to [__] I have to kill
this guy now I gotta I gotta help her we
have to rescue her and the first thing
that comes to mind isn't oh she might be
exaggerating she might be doing I I
because I feel like after you beat the
[__] out of the guy she's like why did
you do that and I'm all like I thought I
thought we're supposed to and then
you're like realizing oh wait maybe it's
not what she said it was you think she
might be lying well she's stretching
she's stretching I don't know I mean in
my maybe udon was really bad maybe she
really messed up that udon so in in
texts
that the woman sent to Jonathan major
uh-oh new development she says they
assured me that you would not get
charged they said they had to arrest you
as protocol when they saw the injuries
on me and knew we had a fight I'm so
sorry you're in this position we'll make
sure nothing happens about this I told
him it was my fault for trying to grab
your phone
and another message sent hours later she
wrote I reiterated how this was not an
attack and they do not have my blessing
on any charges being placed I read the
paper they gave me about strangulation
and I said Point Blank this did not
occur this should be removed immediately
that's what the chick is saying chick is
saying that in text messages to Jonathan
Majors whoa so is it a Stockholm
syndrome situation is it like because
you know in a lot of domestic violence
cases women get beat the [__] up the
guys passionately apologize baby I'll
never [__] do this to you ever again
right and then um she goes okay okay I
believe you I believe you I gotta fix
you we're gonna work through this and
then she'll cooperate yeah that happens
a lot right the problem is maybe because
this is coming from his attorney oh yeah
so we don't know that this is verified
this is just like his attorney's saying
this is what's being said
it's kind of a [__] up thing if she's
lying obviously but you never know it's
also a [__] up thing and she's telling
the truth because that doesn't exactly
sound yeah it doesn't add up like he
didn't do it right yeah it sounds like
he did it I'm just trying to save your
phone the situation and she didn't know
it would go that far wow that's what
that sounds like because it sounds like
the stereotypical domestic violence
thing where the woman starts blaming
herself for like yeah oh I'm so sorry
yeah I shouldn't have touched her phone
I shouldn't have swore you said not to
swear around pretty standards plus this
is clearly like the [__] and Nicholas
Cage our favorite actor in Conair in
that scenario where it's like hey look
you were in the Navy or marine or
whatever so you're considered a Lethal
Weapon you're not a regular dude so you
got to go to jail for this one this
[__] just got off training for
creed so if he's boxing his ass off all
day long and then punch the woman but
it's not acting though stunt fighting's
a little different he just hit the heavy
back those ones stunt ABS
he's a good villain honestly Creed but
like I said that was busted like he's
ripped because I like I like Mr T what
was his uh clever like oh he was good a
good one but that's on Rocky yeah wait
did he come on creep too no okay but
just in the whole franchise I liked him
I only watched one I didn't watch you
don't watch for like Rocky two or three
no the Creed I only watched one Creed
well actually created franchise yeah
Creed two is a is a phone because how
many are how many is there there's three
because this one's called Creed Three
what the way I see it I see Creed one as
Rocky six so it's like Rocky six seven
and eight that's how I see it well
actually that's the issue because
Sylvester Stallone or Sly if you want to
call him that Ashley had an issue with
the Creed 3 uh movie and because there
was some sort of like conversation where
even though in the script it was kind of
like it's this is your time just blah
blah blah like it was supposed to like
move on from the rocky era yeah he still
apparently got upset that they wrote him
out of the script and the story for
Creed Three like the director and does
he make money off of it though well I
know he he's he's never cut into the
entire Rocky franchise upset about that
he's big time Big Time said about that
yeah that's been always a producer who
owns it really you know kind of [__]
him out of it so Creed what because uh
Sylvester's in Creed one and two and two
it's not really part of it like he
doesn't own it it's not his story
but his
his story is still coming
it's a rocky Universe yeah I mean it's a
Creed's son Madonna's Creed who battled
Rocky like you know Apollo it all comes
it all comes from right oh that's the
sun she wrote but then he sold it right
so then that that those rights
transferred oh sold it he was a [__]
you shouldn't have sold it well he he
was a he sold his dog to make the
[__] that was the sacrifice he made
yeah Play Rocky he had to buy his dog
back yeah to get his dog back
yeah I thought he sold it after two and
his dog died so then he's like he lost
everything all Salon damn
Jonathan Majors punched that chick
[Music]
foreign